la noticia de las últimas horas ha
llegado Como un huracán a Ucrania que en
los últimos días viene debatiendo el
éxito de esa contraofensiva que inició
hace un par de semanas para liberar esos
territorios ocupados por Rusia desde el
comienzo de la invasión las autoridades
reconocen que estaba siendo mucho más
difícil de lo esperado y que iba mucho
más lenta y llega luego en este momento
en el que prigo sin lidera esta rebelión
dentro de Rusia la cual siguen aquí como
una película desde este país
especialmente en esos canales de
Telegram que están más activos que nunca
también se pronunció el presidente
y dice que aquel todo aquel que escoge
el camino del del tiende a
la destrucción y también hablaba de que
la propaganda por meses había tratado de
ocultar los fracasos de Rusia pero que
en este momento era imposible hacerlo
también la mano derecha del presidente
esta mañana ponían las redes sociales
una foto de Él junto al resto de los
generales del ejército ucraniano
asegurando que estaban junto a celencia
a diferencia de lo que pasa en Rusia Así
que cada minuto de lo que pasa que es
seguido con atención y creen que
cualquiera que sea el desarrollo
beneficiará al frente de batalla las
tropas ucranianas que libran como decía
una gran lucha en este momento